[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with somebody interesting from the
internet and this week the person is
joining us at the roundtable of dent dim
lighting is Dane bodenheimer Nona filmed
lighting known to fans as daneboe known
to us is Dane he's the creator of
probably the largest or most successful
crossover series of all time moving from
the internet to TV you may have heard of
it it's called The Annoying Orange
that's right it it's an orange with a
mouth superimposed on what Danes mouth
superimposed on right as well as Danes
eyes superimposed on it I I think
technically it's one of his eyes
superimposed twice it's the same eye
yeah doubled which may be part of the
key to the success along with well all
the other factors which we talked to
Dana bout it premiered as a one-off
video in October 2009 and now has over
152 million views I'm talking about just
that first episode of The Annoying
Orange here's a clip hey Apple what you
look fruity yeah
that was hilarious hey hey Apple what
can you do ten push-ups in ten seconds
what kind of question is that I don't
even have arms how am I gonna do one
push-up hey what hey Apple what can you
do this okay with that initial success
of that video Dane got the bright idea
to start a channel that was wholly
devoted to the Annoying Orange it's
called real Annoying Orange that was a
good decision because that channel has
since racked up two billion that's
billion with the bee that's like almost
a third of the world's population views
in a 2012 Cartoon Network picked up the
series and adapted a television with
Danes to running the behind-the-scenes
production operation the high fructose
adventures of Annoying Orange
[Music]
he's ours
[Music]
since then that television show has had
two seasons 60 episodes but Dane hasn't
stopped on the internet he's still
cranking out weekly episodes of The
Annoying Orange and also making videos
on his own jet to at least two active
YouTube channels with a lot of content
we had a great conversation with Dane
he's got a lot of interesting life
experiences that he shared with us one
of which was how to deal with
inappropriate pictures while working at
a one-hour photo lab it's touch and go
with that also how he worked in the
middle of nowhere North Dakota where he
grew up and then his move to Bakersfield
California where he found meth heads
rolling around in his front lawn quite a
shock never happened to me no I'm but
I'm glad it happened to him so you could
tell us about it and obviously we talked
about the many creative iterations that
eventually led to creating the internet
and TV phenomenon that is the Annoying
Orange so here it is our ear biscuit
with Dane I watched that the video you
did where you listen to yourself on
delay and ice cream ever oh my god yes
do you fall victim to it oh yeah because
there are some people who don't really
you know we're on the mythical show we
have a fine brother and brothers were on
there and neither one of them are
susceptible to it like they had no
problem at all
whereas we get on there and it's just hi
I'm the guy and that I love not able to
yep that's totally what it is so you
tried this in like your spare time well
what happens is we do every Monday
morning we have a Google hangout with my
whole crew cuz some of the guys work
remotely and for whatever reason you
know sometimes like video hangout yeah
video hangout but for whatever reason
there's you know feedback yeah and then
you're talking and you can hear yourself
talking and then pretty soon you like I
can't hear what okay now I can talk you
know yeah headphones off yep
yeah I mean there's I don't know what it
says about the fine brothers but there's
something about the you just letting go
and just talking and no women you magic
sound like a complete
idiot yeah I'm the worst when it comes
to that so yeah now going to your studio
mm-hmm
was I think I said this when we were
there and we were doing our guest spot
for the annoying orange mm-hmm it was
kind of like a dream come true it was
like like or like a field trip like you
see you watch this show and and you
can't your friends are getting to go on
the field trip when do I get to and what
is it gonna be like when I get there are
there gonna be paddle boats yeah and the
best field trip we went on in grade
school was to Pullen park and there were
paddle boats and that was the only
disappointment I gotta say that I don't
know [ __ ]
that's next all this but it was it was a
very cool experience being guest on
Annoying Orange especially because we
got to be rappers yeah yep you get to be
the rapping fries grab Chris cut and cut
Chris yeah
well um you know I I had made
assumptions about how the process would
work or whatever the one thing that I
had not thought of was how still our
heads had to be right yeah so you said
it's down this in the stool you sit
right down in the stool first I might
let go first cuz if this is gonna hurt I
want to know I didn't know yep you can
see how it goes so you sit down in the
stool and I think you told me to put his
head back if you want to put your head
back you can but it was basically the I
saw you set up the camera just film his
mouth and I mean you've got this down to
a science right at by this point I mean
it's been five years this stinks because
the first thing that happened was I sat
down and I I wanted to move my mouth to
express myself especially when you move
your whole head yeah yeah we move your
whole head when you're adopting a
character has this affected the way that
you communicate in life could you find
yourself like keeping your head still
now when you're talking honestly I bet
you I have to wonder actually I mean if
somebody you know if they did a study of
me like you know starting five years ago
to now because I can tell I had motion
study you
you know I'm just saying if they did
okay a head motion study and you could
be able to track now your head moves I
can tell your heads not moving that much
when you're talking you might be right
actually I was gonna say that I think
his head is moving and normal normal it
I was saying I think that normal head
movement while talking right it's it's
it's kind of funny because you learn how
to keep your head extremely still and
emote as much as possible but still move
the rest of your body like using your
hand to gesture and things like that
when you're you know saying something
angry like I hate this very much but you
can keep your whole body very still what
character is that that was my dad you
know I feel like it was a success I
haven't seen our Chris cut crisscross
guests yet it hasn't come out yet as of
this taping but it was a grand
experience oh yeah and you said five
years of getting this thing down to a
science
I want to thank you for the experience
it was it was like paddle boating paddle
boating you guys were Naturals you know
like there's a lot of people and no
disrespect to anyone that comes in and
sits down because it's a little I don't
know it it's it's hard to sit down in a
chair and then you've got these lights
shining at you they're like two feet
away and you've got a giant camera in
your face and somebody's saying you know
keep your head completely still don't
move at all right but be excited and say
you're you know say your lines with a
lot of emotion it's it's hard to do it
all and a lot of people come in and get
a little freaked out and so they're very
kind of timid and they don't you know
really get into the candor but you guys
came in sat down and rocked it out it
was fun you've had some high-profile
guests on that thing I mean from the
start it was you've always incorporated
youtubers but you've had some some
mainstream celebrities in there too over
time right so back in the day I got a
cold call email and this company wanted
James Caan to be on the show to help
promote whatever they were trying to
promote and so I got to go to his house
and meet him and it was just me with a
camera sat down filmed him you're like
I'm just gonna he knew you're just gonna
fill my mouth
yep I mean he kind of knew I mean he
kind of knew what was going on but at
the same time really didn't it was a lot
of fun actually he was a really you know
gregarious gregarious guy he just told a
lot of really weird stories and he would
go off on tangents in the middle of a
line it was you know he really yeah it
was fun
could he keep his head still yeah he
actually did a really good job he was a
good head Stiller yes what part did he
play he played jalapeno okay
very sexy was was it justine one of the
first guests or yeah
yeah she was the first guest before that
it was like Bosnians was he helping you
out at the time no Bobby wasn't really
helping I mean he was he was one of my
buddies yeah you know good friend at
that time and he was kind of watching
this whole thing grow but he was
actually in the same episode that
justine was in so okay he I was the
first episode with with other people
right so well let's go back to the to
the beginning of you before we go back
to the beginning of orange so where'd
you grow up
North Dakota well there's people there
there there is all the howl of like 20
now what was the situation the situation
was it it's a little town right outside
of Fargo North Dakota called Harwood
growing up I was well in college I was
known as the Harwood hustler cuz I
hustle the hard streets of Harwood with
like like playing pool or what nothing
selling drugs because it started with an
H exactly durations yeah cause you were
compensating for something I don't know
what I don't know what I've been facing
I would I put faces on food what can I
say the the movie Fargo how do you deal
with that when you grow up so close to
Fargo it's funny you know that was what
I loved that movie by the way but many
people from that area do not because you
know they'll you know people will ask
them Oh have you seen the movie Fargo oh
we don't sound like that
and they absolutely do everyone has that
accent
back there oh we're going to the bar you
know that bad accent yeah it's it's
people don't think that they have it
what is your parents do there well my
mom was a pregnant wife Cheryl I wish I
wish well my dad was a roofer my mom
worked all kinds of different jobs she
you know would work like factory jobs
she worked a lot of nightshift kind of
things but right now she works with
developmentally developmentally disabled
excuse me I can't tell she's a true hero
yes yes my dad's not around anymore okay
he passed a few years ago but my mom's
still around my brother's back there
still he's going to school so now you
were doing an impression of your dad
earlier yes was that this is how he
talked yeah when he was angry yeah did
he get angry at you occasionally um yeah
yeah he got angry at all of us you and
your your I know you have a brother
yeah Luke right mm-hmm and then who else
is in the family that's it okay my
brother my mom okay yeah two brothers in
the immediate family anyways right Hans
of cousins and aunts and uncles and all
kinds of things I mean so what do you
what do you do in North Dakota for fun
as a kid
nothing there's not much to do and that
was the whole thing like you know
obviously you you know hang out with
your friends get in trouble go tip cows
that kind of thing no that's not
possible
we've tried it yeah yeah we have now
joking we're from another north we have
tried it so I mean that's what we did
funded North Carolina attempt to yeah
there's just you know that was the thing
there wasn't a ton to do so you just
kind of had to use your imagination and
one of the things you know when I was 12
my my parents got a camcorder for the
family and as soon as they got that
camera I hijacked it and it became mine
and I used it to make all sorts of you
know short videos with my brother was
this thing full VHS or DVD s it was
eight millimeter Oh like a what is it
supe no it's not super 8 it
yeah it was religiously yeah okay so the
smaller tape-based thing but you could
digitize the footage yep exactly
you weren't editing on VCRs I was in the
beginning yes okay
yeah well Digital eight came out
afterwards like I ate yeah that's what
yeah it's high yeah yeah that's what
usually a little too recent yeah exactly
so you would shoot you would make shorts
but would you edit in camera like yes
shoot this scene and then the next scene
is this so I got to shoot it now so that
it can be laid on the tape right after
the yep exactly but the the it was never
it was obviously never a perfect science
because there was like a one or two
second delay from when you click the
record button so you'd have to you know
say action but then tell the person
don't say your line until two seconds
after I hit record right because because
I'm not gonna edit this that's happening
right now exactly so you get a lot of
cut off lines you got a lot of people
like standing there for a second and
then moving and saying their line so you
immediately started doing scripted
content with the camcorder yep and then
you know playing around you know there
we had a VCR in one room and then a VCR
in another room and so I grabbed those
put them together and then you know tape
to tape pick out those gaps yeah exactly
put in some sound effects even oh wow I
had a what was it it was a tape player
that I hooked the the RCA cables up to
the back of the VCR and then I could put
fart sounds and stuff in the videos and
so when you did that you fart movies
yeah when you do these do you think I
made because cuz this is how I remember
editing you know Lincoln I would shoot
something and then I would take the VHS
see tape I would put it inside the VHS
yeah holder yep put it in the in the VCR
I would go to my dad's office of the law
school and I would take to like VCR
carts that they used in classes and put
them side-by-side and then take the
cables from RadioShack and do the
editing but I don't remember being able
to run like to overdub audio at the same
time or you eventually figured it out
and I said this is good
we have to do it all you had to do it
all at the same time right exactly so
it's like while you were recording video
yep you had that wasn't taped to the
other timber sitting there ready with
the tape player and then you would hit
them in hope to god that the fart sound
came in the same time yeah exactly
there was a lot of hit and miss it's so
amazing that that was a thing that
happened
mm-hmm and it all depends on how old you
are yeah in fairness the fart sound
there's a little leeway with when the
fart comes like if you lean and then
it's a few seconds for the fart comes
well that's normal if you're filming the
bassoon I assume you're a fan of Dumb
and Dumber yes knowing you yes have you
seen the truck new trailer it looks
amazing
well the trailer yeah he names the cab
the hole and he says why do you call him
that and he holds up shows the cats ba
hole
yes yes I've seen the trailer so I mean
I watch that today so they do show cat
ba hole and you had to say like that
ball and it's a trailer a trailer is you
know anybody can see that right oh
that's yeah
so I mean you know the world is changing
so how did you go from foreign movies to
making The Annoying Orange I'm sure you
can answer that in two sentences so I
went from making fart movies to you know
just I kept making them and in there
screenings no I mean there was for my
family that was the whole thing like I
loved making videos with like all my
cousins and stuff and then we'd all
crowd in a big room and watch them
together you might be particularly proud
of anyone oh man okay so I made this
series called demon shadow and it was
about this demon like we it was a ritual
forest like every fourth of July my
family would come out and we'd all get
together for a fourth of July gathering
but
at the same time we had film one of
these demon shadows you had a large cast
yes exactly and they were completely
nonsensical I grew up on horror movies
and comedies pretty much so those were
my inspiration very very cheesy but it
was just about this demon that would
haunt us and every year would come back
to life it's kind of like the you know
Freddy Krueger there's just he can't be
stopped and it would you know we would
in the end to feed him and then he'd
come back the next year so this became a
ritual and I always just loved doing it
and the kids loved doing it
so yeah that'd be cold would you would
you like kill off a cousin every year or
something my god Yuki you can come back
next year but you can't be in the movie
because you died well there's a demon
shadow right but demon shadows got to
kill cousins first yeah well there's
always you know there's always the
danger of that but no none of the
cousins ever got killed one of one of
our buddies got killed in one of them
and then became a zombie who came back
to life and saved us and did any of
these people fart or was that you know
this is post fart movie okay good for
you and have you done how do you kill a
demon shadow oh you can do it many ways
a very offline very often it was with
fireworks since it was fourth of July so
we would get amazed the prop secured
yeah exactly
disposal I think we did that at least
three or four times it became a
reoccurring thing it was like okay
option value we're gonna do this ending
again alright what what are the
fireworks laws in North Dakota because I
assume there's none I seem like there's
cannons there yeah I mean it's pretty
much no-holds-barred
right for whatever reason a few years
back they banned bottle rockets you can
fire off the most insane artillery shell
explosion it doesn't matter but you
can't have bottle rockets because
they're cuz you how can hold them yeah I
apparently I'm not sure hold them yeah
too many woods they just look like it's
like that stick looks like a handle it
does we had many a bottle rocket fight
so yes
so is it like I'm going to film school
no in fact it was you know me just
doing this thing and then you know I got
to the age of I don't know fifteen
sixteen whereas like oh okay I can get a
job now to get extra money so I started
off working this really you know it it
was fun but I would never do anything
like it again we worked out in these
corn fields and we were it was like
cross pollinating different corn stalks
he would second corn yes exactly
with itself Wow Durban but anyways that
was a job for a couple summers but then
I saw the paper one you know was the
next summer that they were looking for a
cameraman for the local Prairie Public
Television or PBS okay that's what Perry
Public televisions prairie public
yes okay that's what it's called back in
in Fargo right but I saw an ad for that
and I was like wow okay maybe I'll give
it a shot that's better than mating corn
exactly so I you know I applied and they
I got the job oh wow and it was awesome
it was so much fun
didn't get paid very much but you got
all the free Mountain Dew and popcorn
you wanted so at the at the ripe age of
16 I was like heck yeah 16 years old
yeah you were like traveling around the
state shooting like public television
studio it was all studio based like they
would do the you know every season they
do the drives to raise money and it was
we would just shoot those film people
answering phones exactly which sounds
boring but it was so much fun
could you just got your cans on and
you're just you know you're jabbing with
the other guys and making fun of each
other making fun of the people answering
the phones which is terrible if you do
that job you can't you can't think that
nobody's you know making some jokes did
that lead did that lead to the next
thing kind of yeah it was when I was
there that you know I was talking to one
of the other girls who worked there and
she she said oh you do film and you know
you really like this stuff you should go
to Minnesota State at the time it was
called Morehead State University which
borders Fargo and they have a you know
they had the beginnings of a film
department
and I was that was when it first hit me
I was like holy crap I could actually do
this for a living
alright I like this so that's you know I
kind of left there with that in mind and
I I made a meeting with the you know the
head over there and you know he was
awesome said you know talked me into it
basically but he didn't really have to
he just gave me the spiel was like you
sold me at hey how are you doing
right and that's you know kind of where
it started went to film school there and
what was the film program like it and
you say it we started to say Minnesota
State is at what's called now yeah it's
called Minnesota State University
Moorhead okay
yes and how many students in the film
program man you know in our kind of
cohort it was like I think like 16
something like that it wasn't a ton so
now it's much much bigger over the few
last few years it's really grown but you
know when I was there we had one 16
millimeter camera nobody knew how to
operate it we had this other guy that
wasn't even affiliated with the school
that would come in and help us run it
but nobody knew how to run it
no matter anyway no I know at the time
we're all like I wish we knew how to we
could do that too cuz it would be really
helpful no it doesn't matter so was
there like demon Shadow the college
years or I wish I well I kept making
them in my own time you know yeah that
was that was my thing you know like you
still have demon shadow on tape I do I
do I've always wanted to upload them to
YouTube but I'm a little hesitant
because they all have like copyrighted
music so I figured maybe I'll just put
them up and not you know obviously not
monetized well you just need to create
the channel demon shadow yeah and then
just you know yep just take whatever
happens right well if we get done with
this podcast and people are like we want
to see demon shadow alright then I'll do
it that's gonna happen so at daneboe on
twitter hashtag demon shadow my cousins
will be very happy oh man I've always
wanted to be featured quite in that way
they're gonna break out demon shadow so
so you were you were getting the proper
schooling but you had the thing that was
even more important that was a drive to
create mm-hmm yes
yeah and that it was funny you know some
of the a couple my good buddies we would
always say like you know we saw some of
the other guys in the department and
again nothing against anybody else but
they would you know just do the required
projects and that was it
whereas like I would do the required
projects and I would get done with them
I'm like I want to do more so I would go
out and do my own stuff and I just you
know for whatever reason just constantly
wanted to keep learning new things got a
computer one of the very first IMAX that
came out you know those colored ones
they were different yeah so I got one of
those so I could use iMovie which is the
most amazing thing in the world to me I
didn't even know it was called iMovie so
iMovie shipped with the first one of
those yeah awful looking things that was
in public libraries what time I was like
wow that was a thing of beauty at the
time you know it was like what this
looks this isn't a computer this is a
lunchbox
you know just was amazing with a tube in
it with like a television tube that you
could see in the back yeah right
yep exactly yeah so I saved up my money
from doing those other jobs bought a
computer and you know just I I did while
I was in college I did a internship at a
claymation film or this guy I think he
was in Grand Forks which was like
probably 45 minutes away out in this
just on his farm way out in the middle
of nowhere was making this claymation
movie
and he wanted someone to help him and my
you know the head of the department came
to me and was like hey this guy wants
help you like animation so you want to
do it I was like heck yeah I'll do it
so I went out there every day drove out
there there and back and just help this
guy and he he I can't remember his now I
think it was Peter but I can't remember
his last name but he he's the one that
kind of showed me After Effects for the
first time and kind of how to use it in
a very general fashion nothing really
in-depth but it was at that point
I was like oh my gosh what were his
characters were they raises no no it was
uh it was they were Knights it was at
like a Knight's Tale I think that was
actually the name of it but his since
been taken by someone else yeah
something might turn into a movie yeah
so that's that's kind of where I got my
first you know dip my hand in the water
my toes in the water with After Effects
and that just you know from there I was
like I love this so much and we're still
probably about I mean we're talking at
least four more years before the advent
of YouTube mm-hmm even from this point
mm-hmm so what was in that four years do
you get married no I met my wife to be
in college and we from there you know
graduated moved to Minneapolis she's an
archaeologist so she was working for
some of the firm's injuries as an
archaeologist yeah how come I didn't
know this no you do well I mean all our
cuz we'd like for her to replace you at
this point
what could it how could benefit you get
right over that but two very fascinating
careers that's interesting yeah she's
she specializes in stone tools so she
can take she knows how to Flint nap so
she can take you know rocks and she hits
him with other rocks and turns them into
does she like travel to remote locations
and yeah stone tools up mm-hmm
see I've only ever seen this on
television mm-hmm or movies and I
thought that it might be a completely
made-up profession know it but now it's
been confirmed I know one yes she
doesn't look like Harrison Ford does she
know senator I told her when she gets
her PhD she's getting a fedora in a whip
there's no like she doesn't get to talk
yeah there's no or you'll let her take
her out take it out in public yeah
exactly
so you moved for her archaeologist job
yeah she got a job out there and then I
wanted to go up there too because
Minneapolis there's a bit more going on
as far as filmmaking so I was like maybe
I can break into something but
and I had no luck there's just there's
not at the time there really wasn't a
lot going out there and I did everything
like I'm I was shameless I would just
show up at businesses with a you know a
resume in hand and say hey I'm looking
for work he got anything and I got ended
up getting a couple of things but they
were you know they weren't they didn't
pay at all but I got to stand there in
the cold and and help out a little bit
but that was about it and what kind of
stuff was that um wrangling Talent okay
for just I think it was a commercial
shoot and then I can't even remember
what the other one was but it was
something similar so it wasn't anything
crazy was just like a one-day shoot got
to do it a couple times in the meantime
I worked at one our photo labs that was
my oh that was my thing Wow so you've
seen you've seen photos oh yes it's like
the archeology of a different countries
actually especially when you know cuz
people one our photo labs there's just
stacks and stacks of photos and people
bring stuff in but then you know they
just don't come back for it so you'll
have you know packages there for four
years and peeling those open and you
know like looking inside its yeah it's
crazy you see some see some crazy stuff
if people take photos of things that are
like inappropriate you're not supposed
to develop those no no in fact I mean we
ended up it's one of those things where
you can't really stop it from being
developed because you developed the
whole roll at it you don't put it in the
right right put it in a pack yep
why not you put in you put it on the
wall in the office it was it was the
procedure was to like you were it was
mandatory that when that happened you
had to actually tell the person like hey
we said we found some naughty photos in
there and we couldn't put them in and of
course they were developed that's what I
don't get and what were this what were
the categories that you couldn't put in
there are you talking nudity yeah I mean
that was like basically illegal activity
I get to have sure but why personal
photo nudity it's North Dakota but I
think that's I think that maybe it isn't
anymore
of course I don't know who's taking
these type of photos and getting them
developed these days but right yeah I
think that's that that was like the wall
but it is a great question because the
person who took them has seen it right
now the person who developed them is
seeing it yeah who are we trying to
protect at this point yeah I shouldn't
say it's just North Dakota it's
everywhere I mean right I remember in
North Carolina too but you would have to
tell the person hey hey Dad that photo
that you took I don't know if that's
your girlfriend or yes it's a
comfortable scenario to like have to say
to someone like we found some new tees
so and what do people say do they are
they create yeah it's either one of two
scenarios the first is like they're like
you know kind of get that bashful look
on their face like oh okay sorry
or it's like what what that's my photo
it's you printed it right and then you
have to say like well yeah but we can't
give it to you just give it to me so do
you have any on you you and Teresa were
you were dating or you were married
yeah we were dating okay so she's like
being archaeologist extraordinaire and
you're like trying to piece it together
mm-hmm I mean is that was that
frustrating you're like oh she's not
gonna marry me if I don't get out of
this photo lab now there was really no
worry about that I mean we neither of us
were really in any rush to get married
or anything like that but it was
frustrating at the same time of course
you know to to really be hungry for it
and want it but not at the same time
kind of not knowing what you want but
just being hungry for it because like I
didn't know at the time like do I want
to do animation do I want to direct do I
want to do this I mean at the at the end
of the day all I kept thinking in the
back of my brain is you know I want to I
don't want to I want to direct movies
that's all I want to do so when was it
where was the breakthrough I don't know
well I guess it was YouTube really that
was that was the big breakthrough from
many
Teresa got into a master's program in
Bakersfield California oh yeah oh yeah
right right on our back doorstep you
drive an hour and a half you will face
the net capital birthplace of Merle
Haggard exactly so we ended up moving
there a great introduction to California
it is it lots of cows and dust and meth
I guess he would say yeah yeah okay
that's methyls of it's funny the first
day that we moved in because we we
didn't get a chance to actually come out
and find a place before we move down so
we got our place online moved out well
you know get there with our moving truck
pull up and we're like oh god this is
sketchy we you know we start moving our
stuff and what did it look like lack of
a better word very good we like you mean
like unsafe yes yes okay a lot of
unsavory types hanging out guys rolling
around on the on lawns obviously on
something there was a guy that that that
was there he would roll around on the
lawn and chase cars you mean like like
as if he were on fire like a person
person at first sausage meant like
driving a car on lawns but fume you know
like bodily rolling yeah yeah like a log
right a log that snorts and yells cars
like a dog yeah so like a log chased
cars like a dog it rhymes so yeah we
were moving our boxes in and you know
getting getting settled and all of a
sudden we hear from from like the walls
were just paper-thin so in the apartment
next to us we hear you and then I was
like okay and then we well you and we're
like okay and it just it starts to
escalate assume that was a woman in a
man yes
no you you want it you want it did you
start hearing this oh wow it's recent I
would like well in the Bakersfield
that was that was her first introduction
to Bakersfield but for a moment you
thought there was gonna be like gunfire
through the through the through the wall
well that yeah I mean that was always a
worry actually it sounds it sounds you
know completely overdramatic but it was
of worry when we moved away from that
place it was the very next week we they
were doing we were watching the news and
somebody got arrested for pulling a gun
at that apartment complex at the pool
and they were there was trying to shoot
somebody but the the gun I wouldn't go
out it wouldn't go off it got jammed and
we were like ah so we actually broke our
lease after three months because we
couldn't take it
right so god yeah we for whatever reason
we made the the people next to us really
angry because we'd complain about the
noise because Teresa is she's in school
trying to do her studies meanwhile
people are blasting their music and so
we would complain I came home one day
went inside came back out dude pissed on
my on the wheel of my car it was like
because they were you know they're tired
of us we got a dead I didn't expect to
go down this road but it was a weird
situation I mean that's pretty hardcore
peeing on a tire well you know does that
mean he now owns the car well yeah he's
marking his territory appeal on all four
tires and then you make it to the spare
you definitely so you got out of the
apartment did you get out of Bakersfield
or yeah of entually eventually we did so
one of the reasons a move to Bakersfield
besides the fact that Teresa got into a
master's program was I was able to get a
job on pimp my ride thanks to a couple
buddies that I went to college with
really yeah and they they shoot up there
in Bakersfield no they actually shoot it
in LA and Inglewood so I would commute
from Bakersfield to Inglewood Wow
probably twice a week but I would stay
with them during the week they were nice
enough to let me crash on the couch and
more so what was your what was your job
there
production assistant okay sweeping
floors at first so you were in the
student you weren't like on location
with exhibit like hey I'm here at this
car and I'm about to pimp it back in the
studio hearing footage of him say hey
I'm at this car I'm gonna be it was kind
of in the middle actually I didn't work
I mostly did not work at the at like MTV
studios what I did was I worked at the
garage where they would do all the work
but that's the best part
me and my buddy Spencer who actually is
like been with me from the beginning
yeah with orange it was me and him
that's what we did man we just we hung
out at the at the garage all day long
they were literally pimping the ride
exactly we it was pimping 24/7 baby did
you pick up any bodyworker
uh you know surprisingly no it was
terrifying the first day you walk in
because these are you know these are
rough and tough dudes that work there
but you know it's it's standard
procedure that you gotta you got to
rough up the new guy a little bit give
him give him a good ribbing so everybody
was you know like guys would I would I
would ask guys questions and they'd be
to just look at me
whatever and they'd turn around and walk
away and then I'd see him way off in the
distance they'd be like you know talking
to their buddies and they'd just be
laughing and laughing on laughing man so
in the beginning it was scary and I
remember my first week I hated it I was
like I everyone hates me you know
whatever but then after a little bit
it's totally one of those things like
you know you're around him enough they
start talking to you pretty soon
everybody gets along and they're just
they're awesome dudes it was a lot of
fun actually to be down at the garage
these guys and tiny skinny white guy
amongst okay
all these rough and tough guys and so
did did YouTube start to bubble up at
this point or was it it was jobs it was
closed so it was right around that time
I think towards the end of when I was
working on pay my ride that YouTube
started to become a thing I remember
sitting in I had we had we had a trailer
out back I remember sitting in the
trailer making a myspace page and it was
yeah it wasn't short short there too
long after that that and when did you
introduce a get married two years ago
okay so that was that was more recent
yeah okay
we had been been together for 10 years
around those 10 years yeah you guys been
together a decade yeah okay so as you
begin to work on Pat my ride making that
MySpace page yeah makin a myspace page
what was the what was the thought at
that time because you know I mean the
traditional model still a lot of people
who follow this it's like I'm gonna get
a job as a PE on a TV show I'm gonna
work my way up to whatever and then you
know I'm gonna be in the business yeah
it was at a strategy at the time kind of
yeah I mean that was you know me and my
buddies and everybody that was on the
show that was kind of the you know the
way that things were done if you were in
that position you just got to work your
way up and I kind of did you know from
PA I was able to actually parlay that
and work on a creative team with a
little help from Spencer actually he
helped me get a position on a creative
team where I got to actually shoot and
do some writing write some of the bits
on the show things like that so that was
a lot of fun but you know at the end of
the day things didn't quite work out and
after I was done with it I just you know
I was it kind of left a bad taste in my
mouth because I was just like this isn't
quite what I want to be doing it just
doesn't feel right so I was like I don't
think I want to do TV but while we were
while I was working at him I ride and we
were you know working our butts off you
know we would come home at night and we
just make stupid videos like we had
always done back in college and whatever
and it began with we we made our own
website called gagfilms comm where we
were just uploading our stuff there it
was a lot of like old college buddies
that would just go on the site and leave
comments and watch it and stuff like
that and that was kind of our vision was
like hey what if we created the site
where everybody could put videos you
know and then it wasn't shortly too long
after that that YouTube popped out of
nowhere so you almost made YouTube
almost just that close to I don't want
to go there yeah
actually had a lot of people ask me when
I said oh we have the sight gag film I'm
like oh is that that part right did
somebody steal a video from gag Phil's
not come and put it on YouTube or did
you post it on YouTube yourself no I
think we just you know we made a YouTube
page and I just started uploading stuff
there because ironically our first video
on YouTube was stolen from our website
where we were hosting QuickTime videos
mm-hmm
we had a parody of pimp my ride really
with our kids called pimp my stroller oh
my god hope I never seen this we built
because it used it's not all I'm a
playwright of music and it was stick oh
but we pimped out a double stroller we
actually engineered this thing it kind
of looked like the Batmobile
and we put my daughter Lily and his son
lock in it and we like play these
characters we were making fun right yeah
it was like yo we pumped out your
stroller and then it was crazy inning
Rams and ground effects and everything
and we like did the voices of our kids
but you know somebody we know money
stole it and put it on YouTube well but
when we move from North Carolina that
pimp that pimped out stroller double
stroller is is out there somewhere yeah
we off somebody bought three and a half
years ago really fan Wow who came to our
studio so so yeah that video was taken
from our website posted on YouTube and
it got a lot of views like we should
start here to jail were you guys doing
the same exact thing like hey let's put
make a site and put some videos
yeah Retin we were kind they weren't
smart enough to think
let's get other people to put videos out
there but but it's funny because you
know they're just because we're similar
in age it's and had the same type of
aspirations it's funny how there's so
many parallels it's like if you wanted
to be in some sort of entertainment that
involved you making videos you edited on
to VCRs you shot with a certain type of
camera yep then you started your own
website then YouTube came along and
either you were smart enough to put your
videos out there in our case somebody
put a mother for you and so the when you
put them up there on YouTube was early
days I guess 2006 is that one yeah what
was the what was some of the first
videos if you put up the first videos
were stuff that I did back in college
the very first video that I have on my
daneboe channel which is my main channel
is a short called the Yanni show and
it's it's like a kids show slash game
show starring Yanni he teaches about
green light touches and red light
touches and Haggai it goes south very
quickly and needless to say I have
gotten many hate comments from people
that love Yanni that I am a horrible
person for whatever reason back in
college we just we loved you know poking
fun at Yanni I don't know yes the other
night and I was like I just this is
unbelievable Yanni live like he's still
doing is still at it yep
so then what popped because I know
before orange there were talking eggs
yes that was that was probably the first
thing that popped it was we introduced
those eggs
I remember this CW CW online nation yep
I don't know what the intro was I'm sure
it was a really cheesy line had been
written for us it's like you know what
link I'm in the mood for eggs oh yeah
right
an omelet well here you go how about
some eggs would personality Oh
clip I'm sure it was something that bad
yeah I remember this very very well and
so that was on YouTube it was you open
the fridge yep and the eggs that was
like one of my well be very first
talking food video that I did what what
happens you open the fridge yep open the
fridge and there's some unsuspecting
very cute kind of slightly annoying eggs
that are you know kind of bewildered and
like what is going on and then they get
taken out of the fridge and put on the
counter and the whole time they're like
I don't know what's going on what's
happening and you know you see the
frying pan get put on the stove and the
burner goes on and the whole time
they're still talking what's going on
and then all of a sudden Steve gets
grabbed and he gets cracked over the
edge of the frying pan and everybody
freaks out yeah it's always Steve I
don't know what I don't know why but
it's always Steve so it so started with
eggs and then moved on to what well it
started off with eggs because I did that
video for a film contest it was a bolt
calm it was this old kind of networking
sites kind of like MySpace it's now
defunct it's not around anymore but at
the time they were doing this contest
where you make a minute long video
submit it if you win you get $5,000
so I did it and I actually won and I use
that $5,000 to buy a new camera and some
new equipment and you know but why
talking eggs it's a great question it's
a great question I mean it's one of
those things like you you know I always
grew up you know anthropomorphizing
things we all do as kids you know you
make the rocks talk or whatever sticks
trees you know you give them
personalities and you know learning
after effects early on and realizing
that I could actually do that in my
videos just blew my mind and that's why
I just totally gravitated towards that
like okay I can bring anything to life
and it's amazing to think that that
stop-motion guy that you drove ever how
far everyday yep to help him out for
presumably nothing
I taught you After Effects and that
changed everything it totally changed
everything yep
so that would yeah that's definitely one
of those moments you won five grand and
you bought in a better camera yes so you
tx100 oh yeah you guys know yeah ene I
had to be okay
we had an MMA and then we had a beef
nice so did you just put eyes and mouths
on things after the eggs or did you do
other things other things yeah right a
mix of everything right so you know I
like I said make cats talk I had you
know and it was always like humans
interacting with other things that you
know don't normally come alive but they
did in the videos but was it always an
inanimate object or something that
doesn't talk talking no I mean well
quite often yes quite often we'll put
yeah because the eggs really worked it
totally worked
and it's funny like looking back at it
now you know I think about I'm like oh
man I didn't you know I wonder why I
didn't just gravitate towards that right
away you know cuz it really worked and
it just popped and people loved it and
like in other words do a sequel to the
egg yeah exactly and I did actually
probably a year later or something like
that but it was just one of those things
like I want to do all kinds of things I
want to try things out I want to make
explosions you know I want to make giant
demon monsters whatever yeah so and
there was a good three years between
joining YouTube you know six to that
first annoying aren't yo 9 yep and so in
in that three-year period of course you
know if you're talking oh six oh seven
oh eight you're not no partner program
really there's not a lot of money or any
in YouTube it's still sort of hot the
hobbyist yep so what were you doing to
make money in that period of time so
after I made that talking egg video you
know I was continuing to do other things
and then all of a sudden I got an email
from JibJab com I don't know if you guys
know yeah definitely animation site
where you could actually interact with
the website and
upload your photos and they would make
those talk yes at some point yep and
they would also do political satire
music videos that were two-dimensional
animations but they would all have like
moving mouths yep so they saw your egg
thing and they're like ah get this guy
on border we're gonna assassinate him
yeah they called me up and they're like
hey we love this and we want you to come
in and make a whole slew of them and so
when in talk with them and that's what
happened I ended up making I think like
ten of them at least different
variations of kind of this egg structure
so you know and it was all for different
holidays because they were doing just
you know kind of holiday greeting card
ecard kind of thing so you know for the
Super Bowl a bunch of avocados got
turned into guacamole and for for
Christmas a bunch of cranberries got
strung up on you know a string and hung
up on the the Christmas tree and stuff
executed yes and it was all horrific but
funny at the same time a lot of animated
violence so it played really well and it
would it did really well for their site
and you know I had a lot of lot of fun
doing it and I actually got to like work
with a legitimate crew have a cameraman
things like that so it was a good
learning process there too and those
guys hands down some of the best dudes
Evan and Greg over there they are one of
the reasons why I'm at where I'm at like
those guys really nurtured me so but you
didn't make the orange for them nope I
didn't nope
I think goodness for that yeah it was
shortly after that I had done all those
JibJab videos I still doing my thing
every once in a while I'd do a talk in
food video and that was really it it was
just gonna be you know I came up with
this idea you know it was lying in bed
one night and just you know cuz I you
know before I'd fall asleep just come up
with ideas and that just popped into my
head like Oh would it be hilarious if
this you know if this Apple was annoying
this orange and then it got knifed and
you know and just kind of that that
escalation of being annoyed to death
what did you switch it because yeah I
said that oh yeah in the beginning it
was going to be the other way around but
then when I started animating it I still
hadn't like really really perfected the
animation process even though I had done
tons of these so as you know as I was
animating I was like looks like the face
on the orange looks so much better I'm
gonna make it The Annoying Orange so I
swapped it Wow
so it was almost The Annoying Apple yes
it was almost but it was good that I
didn't go that way because then you know
orange could say you're an apple and you
know there's that you know kind of thing
going on the its you know up to over 150
million views now it was so it was one
of those videos that everybody passed
around back then and continues to get a
lot of views having just watched it
today to kind of just to refresh as a
refresher on it I'm just reminded at how
much the violence at the end is is
really the kiss that is the hook mm-hmm
you know it's like it's funny throughout
I mean it's just a hilarious video that
first iteration and the annoying are
you're laughing throughout and then of
course just this unexpected like oh this
is gonna happen and and that was kind of
what that was sort of the the plot line
with with everything in short right it
was like I would add that it was
obviously the great ending was this
knife and then you know it's like
slicing an apple is I think more
satisfying than slicing orange - so I
got you one on that one but then it was
that the button of Bennet it pans over
to the payer mm-hm yep and that you got
that extra big laugh and it was just
perfect but it set up another one I
don't even know if the second one after
that was a pear no it wasn't but you
kind of get this oh now he's gonna talk
to this pear and what else is this
aren't you gonna talk to I'm gonna keep
watching and I'm and I'm I could be five
years old or I could be 55 I could be
105 and I'm gonna watch the next one
yeah because I'm annoyed by this orange
in a very delightful way
did it blow up instantly it took a few
weeks but after a few weeks it hit a
million and then slowly just started
getting more and more millions was there
someone who talked about it at that
early stage that was like helped it blow
up or was it just just everybody it was
yeah I mean it was it really was organic
you know I don't remember anyone ever
you know talking about it or featuring
it or anything like that it was just it
started to get a lot of traction and
then suddenly I was getting tons of
emails from kids and make more you know
we love this and so I you know luckily I
left the character in alive at the end
so I could make some more because it was
never intended to be more than just one
video so you know but at that point
where you're like all in orange orange
orange no not even then it wasn't until
the fourth episode that I uploaded and I
was like holy crap because I was right
before Christmas I uploaded that video
and the next day it had a million views
which at that time was that's
gangbusters so I was like there's
something going on here so at the time I
was doing client work and YouTube at the
same time I was off on vacation for
Christmas I got home I made an annoying
orange YouTube dedicated page and just
decided right then and there like hey
this is what I'm doing I'm gonna I'm
gonna try and make this work cuz you
know now is the time right
so from there I just you know I kind of
dedicated myself to you okay now I'm on
a schedule every week I'm gonna do
another one of these cuz that was kind
of the schedule at the time for
everybody is like just do a video a week
and you know get on a schedule so Friday
became the day so every Friday was a new
annoying orange video was it difficult
to maintain that schedule did you oh
yeah because of the work that went into
it
writing the shooting to add any in the
compositing yeah yeah I mean I would not
have been able to do it without Spencer
I I did the first couple episodes and
then you know by the third episode I was
already starting to get stumped a little
bit you know as far as like coming up
with puns
in terms of writing yeah so I hit him up
cuz he's the he
the master of puns it's ridiculous and
then in terms of like the the keyboard
work was that time-consuming to I mean
was it did like the animating yeah yeah
that took so long I mean it was we would
basically the structure became Spencer
and I would talk on Sunday for an hour
to come up with okay what's this next
video gonna be he would script it and
have the script done usually by Monday
and we maybe do some revisions it'd be
very quick revisions and then you know
we'd have it locked by Monday night and
then Tuesday would record all the mouths
and then you know spend the next two
days animating it and upload on Friday
and that became that was the structure
for many many many many weeks I was your
life yeah life for a while yet it but it
was rewarding because it went up it was
working and it was working totally it
was fun it has so much fun after
everything you had done I mean hearing
your story it had to have been
satisfying wow this is really happening
yeah yeah it was crazy and to go on
YouTube and see the videos featured
everywhere you know at the time they
would actually feature videos all over
the site and just just seeing it
featured and you know seeing like I
would upload a video and within you know
an hour it would have thousands and
thousands of thousands of likes and
favorites and you know comments and
whatever and people were so engaged and
there was no negativity whatsoever it
was crazy you know like you know fred
was kind of the other annoying character
at the time I always felt really bad
because you go to his videos and look at
the comments and they were chests nasty
people say some nasty things
but there really wasn't any of that with
orange and anytime anybody did say
anything bad the rest of the community
would stand up and say hey don't you
make fun of orange he's funny you know
right what are you thinking
usually when you go back to something
monstrously successful on YouTube when
you look back at the first one it's like
oh yeah I want actually one even that
good you know that's the thing that was
when I was I was very pleasantly
surprised to rewatch the first one that
it was very much intact I think a
testimony to a process of well it wasn't
an orange but you had mastered a lot of
other things that everything came
together in a way that you never could
have imagined or planned right exactly
that I mean if you you can't point to
any one thing
but it's kind of a confluence of
everything mmm yeah the writing the I
mean everything mm-hmm but it's very
cool that even in that first one it's
like oh this is a template this is not
it would be great it was and so you you
you go you start making these videos
every single week and you're getting
this amazing popularity and of course
you know we know part of the rest of the
story is moving on and having it adapted
into a television show but wasn't it
before that that the because like beyond
it we came bigger than YouTube I mean
all of a sudden there was merchandising
involved and there was you know little I
can't remember what year it was but I
started seeing Annoying Orange key
change and then pajamas and then all the
eight all this television show yeah it
well it started before then especially
there was a lot of t-shirts and things
like that but like I think oh man maybe
the toys actually were before yeah the
toy the toys were before the TV show too
so yeah there was a lot that was out
there before that I felt so cool going
into Toys R Us that Christmas like I
guess that was that was so surreal and
it was like at the cashier you know the
let the impulse buy stuff whenever was
Orange there's like obviously there I'm
sure you're like screaming in Toys R Us
no the guy I think I was phone number in
like my phone call I know that mouth so
you're seeing this thing blow up like
this and I know you it's one of those
things where you're in conversations
with people and you're like oh yeah
let's do this
merchandising thing and they're all
gonna make keychains or pajamas or
t-shirts or whatever it might be but how
it does it feel what would you remember
the first time you saw it on a shelf yes
there was a hot topic uh-huh
there was actually a bunch of a bunch of
youtubers that had gotten stuff in hot
topic I don't know were you guys in
there too or not and part of that wave
okay like Shane Dawson was one of them I
think Charlie the Unicorn and there was
a bunch of people so it was cool to
actually go there and not just see my
stuff but a whole wall of youtubers that
was it was at that point where I was
like ah that makes me proud right those
are my boys and then it gets on
television but it's a different
iteration I mean is there what what's
the perspective on okay this is what you
did here and it worked here but for this
to be a television show it does have to
be something different well yeah that
was always I mean everyone always came
to us and they were like you know when
we'd go and pitch and stuff and talk
about it everyone we always say like how
do you translate two-minute video online
to you know TV show well you do that by
concentrating on the characters and
character development and going on
adventures it's not you go from just
this witty dialogue quick things that
happen and then you know the knife
moment whatever because that's what the
web show was to now hey we can actually
explore all of these personalities and
how they work together and you know that
kind of thing and that was actually the
most fun part of the TV show is doing
that kind of thing you know really
diving into those personalities and you
know finding out that marshmallow is
this cute character that loves
everything but kind of has a dark side
that comes out every once in a while you
know is these you really get to play
with those sorts of things a lot more
didn't you have the opportunity to work
with some pretty amazing veterans in the
animation business when you sort of
developing the show yeah it was I mean
you know with development you know Tom
Shepard came in and he he had worked on
so many things like pinking the brain
one of my favorite cartoons so you know
having guys like him come on and then
conrad vernon of madagascar fame a bunch
of other stuff too working with those
guys it was amazing and then you know
having a whole studio filled with people
just working on putting faces on fruit
was very very surreal and a lot of fun
and you've had two seasons up to this
point yeah and that went really well I
mean what was the experience for you
amazing great experience it was beyond
amazing I mean at the time it sucks
because at the time I was so busy you
know because we were trying to do the
web show at the same time cuz my whole
philosophy was you know going into it
which was also kind of hard to get
across to a lot of people was like you
can't cut off the web show cuz the web
show was where it was all born that's
where the audience is now you got to use
that to push the audience to this new
bigger thing you know and they
cross-promote each other and they work
together just like two strains of corn
but you you were working yourself like
crazy cuz you had to have you have to do
both yeah yeah the web series going
every week yep exactly so it was
constantly running back and forth from
from that to the web show and then back
and forth and back and forth so it was
hard to like really sit down and you
know take it all in and really enjoy it
but you know I say that but I'm not I'm
not saying that I didn't enjoy because I
really really did but it you know at the
time looking back I'm like gosh I wish I
would have just stand sat around more
and just you know took it all in a
little bit but what's your focus at this
point I know that on the orange Chan
what you mean you've got your own
channel daneboe channel which you
there's things happening there but and
then even within the orange channel on
youtube there is seems to be a lot of
different things that are that are
happening there so so what's the
strategy what's your focus be it
television daneboe orange or the orange
series or other things on the orange
channel it's all of those things
actually we're continuing to do stuff on
the demo channel here and there we've
got you know we're always doing stuff on
The Annoying Orange Channel every Friday
still and now we do stuff every Monday
it's usually like gameplay videos
because obviously everyone loves
gameplay on YouTube and then Wednesday
we've kind of hold we've kind of held
four new IP you know we did our first
new show about half a year back called
the misfortune of me being Ned excuse me
and it was an animated show cartoon it
was a lot of fun to do and it kind of
taught me the whole process of making a
cartoon and it is a much more daunting
task than I ever would have thought so
but yeah kind of just exploring and
experimenting with you know the whole
medium because really it used to be you
uploaded once a week and that was kind
of the model but now it's become much
more normal for people to upload you
know multiple times a week if not
multiple times a day it's kind of what
the algorithm Rize geared towards so
we're just kind of playing with that I
mean and with having five years of
orange that's what she said right
there's five years of orange under your
belt
yeah the I would imagine there's a
challenge to keeping it relevant
keeping it top of mind I mean you can't
expect to do the same thing and get the
same results exactly exactly so how does
that work I mean is it is it frustrating
views aren't the same that they used to
be in one sense no no and it's it's it's
it's tough because you don't want to go
down that road where you're just a slave
to the views but it's so hard not to be
you know because when it's star
it's getting down that road you start
enjoying it a lot less and you start
worrying okay like ah I worked so hard
on this video but it didn't make its
money back and so now what am I gonna do
and you know so it's it's tough in that
way but you know ultimately we just we
try and do something new
with every single episode whether it's
whether it's a 3d shot or you know
something that we haven't tried before
just to keep it fresh and then always
you know trying to bring new people on
like you guys and you know new people
that are getting popular on YouTube I
still find it amazing we had Chester
Chester C come in a while ago and he
came in and he was you know he's been
blowing up and so I was worried that he
wouldn't even want to be on the show
like you know our dinky show whatever
but he came in he's like are you kidding
me man I totally want to be on this show
it's like you know it's a rite of
passage it's a youtube rite of passage
you got to be killed so it's I'm
continually amazed by the YouTube
culture and you know everybody working
together still you know it's it's a good
thing to fall back on especially when
you get frustrated you know it's a it's
a big family and that's that's a very
comforting thing well we're glad to now
be considered part of the ranks the dead
ranks and hang out with you and hear
your story it was a lot of fun thanks
for coming in thank you gonna kill you
oh I'm gonna do what you told me to do I
was sitting there in the booth and
you're okay now just yell I just
encourage you to yell like you're dying
okay here we go
that's good cut sign the table sir
[Music]
and there it was our conversation with
Dane Oda Kaymer I really had a good time
talking with Dane I think there's this
dynamic when we talked to someone on a
near biscuit that's a similar age to us
that's found a way to be successful on
YouTube we there's a similar path
because there was a many years of
development before YouTube came about
where you were making videos I mean if
you track with us it's the whole editing
videos on to VCRs as a kid and finding a
way even in the college years to make
videos and find an outlet still before
YouTube was invented well and one of the
interesting phenomenons when that's your
story is that you have something that
you made that no one knows about unless
you tell them about it like for him it's
demon shadow you know for us it's
gutless wonders yeah you have that thing
that you that you began or you made that
you showed the family members that you
don't want the Internet to see although
Dane did say he was possibly willing to
put it on the Internet at some point I'd
like to see daemon shadow yeah and you
know and he got married before the whole
YouTube thing happened not true he met
his wife he met his wife met his wife
who is now his wife but yeah he's been
but they were they were a longtime
couple I think yeah so it's just it's
just a different it's a different thing
and what you see today with YouTube it's
these kids who you know I don't know
they don't know who they're dating next
what do I know what videos coming out
and it's just a different dynamic it's
been wrong with that it's just it's good
to connect with somebody who's got sort
of a similar similar background but not
old we're not old oh no no no it's not
I'm not saying that 50 is the new 30 is
that thing is there's somebody who just
said whoa right like you're 50 what it
won't be too long brother
tweet at daneboe not danbo I
accidentally left the first a out and it
it's just some other dude I don't know
who it is it's somebody but you know
what you should tweet at dambo and say
what are you in dude come on now it's
too close to
well but not really sweet it daneboe and
let him know what you thought of his ear
biscuit we certainly appreciate the time
that we spent together we also
appreciate you reviewing ear biscuits on
iTunes so give it some ratings also
comment on SoundCloud we appreciate all
of this as way to support ear biscuits
and mostly we just appreciate your ears
ingesting our ear biscuits that's true
so just bring your ears back next week
and we'll bring the biscuits
it's a beautiful arrangement we promise
[Music]
[Music]